our CDs Lewis fresh off a three
touchdown performance for the
Jacksonville Jaguars over in London
joining us here on the Rich Eisen show
how you been marseille DS it's been a
long time I'm doing fine
so should should the team just go and
move to London you guys do pretty well
over there what do you think I don't
know about that okay it's definitely our
second home for sure
so how put into words the level of
fandom that you came across over in
London for the game that you personally
witnessed over the years most yeah you
know what it's uh it kind of feels like
you know you need growing up in Long
Beach California I'm going to UCLA and
just being around in LA how that is
there it's kind of like that footage as
I think you know obviously being our
fifth time playing over there it's like
I don't know so we just felt at home
that make us feel welcome
it's been a great opportunity for us to
go over there and you know obviously you
know Bill you know awareness on
organization worldwide you know so it's
been a dope experience and this is your
12th year in the NFL I cannot believe
that a dozen hair flew by it sure did
and then you just had a career day here
with you so you you've had a front-row
seat for the Jacksonville Jaguars
franchise I guess twists and turns since
2006 how has Blake bortles different
Marseille days everybody's waiting for
him to just start progressing every
single game as opposed to the regressing
that we've seen on occasion or more than
often than not how is he different well
I think you know where Blake is really
took strides is mentally I think
psychologically is at a different place
or you know he's growing up you know
obviously every game is not going to be
your best game and if you're blessed
enough to play in this league for a long
time you know it's going to be a couple
years you warm back but you know the
point is to grow from it and when you're
faced with adversity to be able to bust
through that door you know what they say
life is 10% of you know what happened
and 90% of how you react to
you know and I think he's at a place
where where we are doing better as a
team we're starting to know what it
feels like to actually win games and not
lose them and so you know his job as a
quarterback to lead us I think he's
starting to figure that out and he's
taking command of that huddle and it's
been really good to see so for those who
may be unfamiliar how tall are you what
are what's your height
you're six seven and so you know what
it's like to be running downhill and
people making business decisions on the
defense trying to come and take you down
Mar Sadie's you know that it looks like
for net for net has that ability to make
people think about tackling him twice
what do you see from your perspective
about that young man from your back yeah
he he's a animal he's a guy with great
feet great visual can take it to the
house to run around you and will
definitely finish his run he always
finishes his room you know I've seen him
a few times now for guys to get around
his feet and trying you know trying to
tackle them and gang tackling I mean
he's still running guys over so he's one
of those guys that you know he has the
world want to be a great running back in
this league well you know it's been a
pleasure to watch his progression so far
and it's a blessing that you know that
he's on our team
well obviously he's part of a depth
chart but I'm wondering is there a three
down territory for him here where he's a
three down back and that's it
rip the knob off what do you think I
think so I think you know he's the guys
you just don't split out he catch the
rock he can catch the rock out of the
backfield you know definitely running in
you told me tabloids he can do it all
I'm impressed Marseille DS Lewis fresh
off a three touchdown performance in the
London game over the Ravens here on the
Rich Eisen show okay now walk me through
how you first heard about the
president's comments over in London and
then what you guys as in a locker room
talked about and what we saw on Sunday
what we threw that Mercedes well you
know obviously
you know the the time was so far ahead
so we're in London still trying to catch
up on sleep or you know having meetings
and everything like that you know my
phone is going off like just buzzing you
know I'm looking at my phone and seeing
all the screenshots and all my group
chats with my friends for my group chats
and my family is just sending you
different things but obviously at that
time you know I made a lot of meeting so
I can't you know really digest what's
really going on until I got out of
meeting that I look at it and it's just
you know I couldn't believe it you know
I mean I don't understand how you know
things like that you know can be said
from somebody in a position that he's
owned in a platform that he has to just
speak the way he speaks I don't get it I
don't understand it so what was the
conversation about about the show of
unity I mean you and the Ravens were the
first up and on foreign soil I might add
during the national anthem so there's a
lot of sensitivities to this subject
what was the conversation about in your
locker room about the show of unity that
that that wound up yes so to convert the
conversation you know honestly was just
about you know whatever we were going to
do do it together and come together as
one I mean obviously mentally man you
can't force anybody to stand up and lock
arms you know few guys you know milled
and you know that's your prerogative you
know I think it's open to interpretation
to how you're going to take it you know
you can't make everybody happy there's
always going to be something said about
it but it like you said is such a
sensitive subject that you know and it's
not going anywhere for a while you know
this is it's a serious and you know with
the social injustice going on you know
the comments on the president just what
do you call it and feel to the fire you
know it's a tough position of being
especially for us athletes and the
platform that we have you know to be on
the forefront and really try to make a
difference but you you're going to have
some people who
you know don't like this for nearly and
you got some people that you know hate
us for standing you know like you can't
win well you were standing Mercedes
Lewis here on the Rich Eisen show your
left arm was interlocked with the right
arm of the owner of the Jaguars who is
reported to have given money to the
Trump inaugural in the inauguration and
we have by the way nothing wrong with
that but I mean here is the president
saying something about NFL players what
was that like with the owner of the
Jaguars shot yeah I mean yeah it was
definitely a situation where you know we
we met as captains two captains the
owner Jim and the head coach and kind of
figured out that that's what we you know
wanted to do you know obviously you know
I can't speak on the owner and not him
something the president or whatever but
the fact that he was behind behind us
and in the car there and what we were
really doing it for and wanted to just
come together and show unity and move at
the end of the day it's all about coming
together and having this country be a
better place to live in because the
state is home right now is this last one
for you on this subject Mercedes a
couple more minutes with Mercedes Lewis
of the Jacksonville Jaguars those who
are on hold who who take the stance that
players should not use the national
anthem for any anything else other than
hand over heart standing at attention
that any demonstration should be taken
place with outside the combines John
Kelly the four-star marine who is the
chief of staff of the president the
United States said today that players
should just stand at attention with
three minutes and then outside and
before the three minutes they can do
whatever they want what do you say to
that Mercedes that's hard to speak on
you know I mean I my stepfather's a
Purple Heart you know obviously standing
and interlocking orange or something
that you know we decided because it was
uh you know somewhere somewhere in the
middle you know obviously you don't want
to be disrespectful flag and knows that
you know far first and fought for us and
apparel
continue to fight for us every day also
you want to you know be woke to a
situation in the social injustice
justices that are going around I'm going
along those were analysis that's a tough
situation all right
Mercedes before I let you go you play
for a guy with who is known for his
military-like precision in Marone
because it comes from Coughlin how has
think changed how has everything changed
I guess attitudinally culturally within
the locker room and organization with
that change Mercedes or definitely our
culture is totally different totally
flipped upside down I can tell you that
you know will create competitive
competitive environment and we expect to
win every Sunday and the product that we
put out there is one that you know we
believe in the process when we believe
in our hard work that we put in there's
no nonsense it's all professional you
know that's what you're going to see
every week or all right Mercedes again
Congrats on the on the big win in London
I mean I don't know if you're aware you
probably were all over there there was
only one member of NFL gameday morning
that shows the Jacksonville Jaguars over
the Baltimore Ravens and the reason why
I'm bringing it up is because it was me
so I guess congrats to you and me is
that what I'm saying Brockman right now
as we go you're really making this about
you I mean we should really be
congratulating Mercedes on a huge win
over there you got it
best of luck against the Jets and beyond
you got okay there's Mercedes little the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on radio stations across the country and
audience
if you liked that video be sure to
download our app don't have any memory
on your phone let's start to delete some
of those slo-mo videos you have and you
know which ones I'm talking about